ми будемо говорити з Сергієм шкарлетом
міністром освіти і науки України пане
Сергію Вітаю Вітаю вас пане Сергію уже
відомо в принципі і не є секретом що
цього року вступна кампанія теж
базуватиметься на мультипредметному
тесті які Минулого року з причин
воєнного стану але для початку хочеться
зрозуміти якісь принципові відмінності
цьогорічної вступної кампанії і
мульти-предметного тесту будуть від
минулорічного Чи все буде ідентично
Дуже дякую за увагу до освіти адже і
особливо доступної кампанії Це мабуть
найважливіший сьогодні питання яке
турбує і викладачів і студентів і
абітурієнтів і батьків і взагалі-то всіх
учасників цього суб’єкту Оскільки ми
говоримо про велику армію наших
випускників це приблизно стільки ж
скільки було і в минулому році
розраховуємо десь 220-220 і 4000 е-е
випускників 11 класів які зможуть
претендувати на вступ до закладів вищої
освіти принциповими є декілька речей
по-перше це змінено термін і часові межі
написання мультиплідненого тесту
сьогодні це буде 23-му році ми плануємо
буде 180 хвилин а також ми дещо маємо
сьогодні суспільний діалог в частині
наповненості на кримінальному мультику
предметному тесту були деякі варіанти
його формування сьогодні в принципі ми
можемо сформувати три предмети за 180
хвилин перші 20 обов'язкові українська
мова та математика далі 5 предметів на
вибір але це ще не затверджено оскільки
Верховна Рада не прийняла остаточну
зміни до закону Про освіту про вищу
освіту в частині формування саме
особливості службової компанії На цьому
році єдиним сьогодні інструментом
залишається класичне ЗНО Але всі
необхідні документи щодо зміни певного
формату вступу на національний
мультипрем'єрний тест вдосконалений в
цьому році виграє Ну от це якраз була
одна з тем розмова активних довкола
мультиплікатного тесту що Минулого року
було три обов'язкових предмети
українська мова математика і історія
України а цього року історія начебто
мала зникнути Наскільки я розумію це ще
не остаточно і Верховна Рада за це буде
відповідати
відповідати буде Міністерство освіти за
наповненістю умови прийому Верховна Рада
має чітко зазначити що згідно закону
можуть бути зміни в частині нескладання
класичного ЗНО а складання саме
національного мультипрем'єктного тесту
історію України ні в якому разі не
зникне з системи тестування підготовки
особливо По гуманітаріях оскільки два
обов'язкових предмети українська мова і
математика забезпечують найбільшу
прогностичну валідність щодо оцінки
знань і є обов'язковими в
оцінці державної підсумкової атестації а
вже далі історію України іноземна мова
хімія біологія будуть обиратися
вступником самостійно на гуманітарні
спеціальності
коефіцієнт який дає максимальну
кількість балів буде звісно
в пріоритеті для історії України з цим
компонентом з 5 наборів вступник може
вступати за будь-яким обраним напрямом
але гуманітарної спеціальності
найбільший коефіцієнт балів буде саме
для історії України але обов'язково
предмети залишається тільки два
правильно так
поки що в моделі тільки два
це якраз і викликало запитання у у
інтелектуалів українських оскільки теза
така що в ситуації війни з Росією знання
історії України є дуже важливим для
кожного громадянина і варто було б
залишити на їхню думку історію України
серед обов'язкових предметів щоб кожен
громадянин міг продемонструвати своє
знання і хоча б підготувався до цього
тесту абсолютно погоджуюсь тезою
українських інтелектуалів стосовно того
що історія України є
надважливішим предметом надважливішим
контентом сьогодні сучасного українця
але не погоджуюсь ніколи з тим що
виключно іспитом маємо спонукати вивчати
історію України це мають батьків це
суспільство кожен свідомий громадянин
чітко знати українську мову історію
України історію культури історію рідного
краю національної традиції Незалежно від
того чи є в цьому із чи немає в цьому
випадку а особливо те що робиться під
примусом воно ніколи не буває на відміну
Так але тоді цей же аргумент можна
повернути і стосовно української мови і
математики
українська мова і математика - Це
дисципліни які забезпечують найбільшу
прогностичну валідність і є
обов'язковими в державній підсумковій
атестації тому тут трошки інші контексти
Добре пане Сергію е-е чи можна буде цей
мультипредметний тест складати
дистанційно Чи це треба буде фізична
присутність абітурієнта його складають в
електронному варіанті але виключно в
тимчасові екзаменаційних центрах
під орудою українського центру
оцінювання якості освіти те саме
складається і в тимчасових
екзаменаційних центрах в інших країнах
Інше питання наприклад для дітей яким
знаходяться на тимчасово окупованих
територіях там інший встував механізм
вступу де діти можуть складати за окремі
процедурою дистанційно
Я цікавлюся тому що дуже багато людей
які будуть складати цей тест перебувають
зараз за кордоном чи є вже і якщо
Минулого року це робилося так поспіхом
можливість скласти цей мультиппредметний
тест з-за кордону то ніби цього року є
час підготуватися і чи є вже якісь
напрацювання в яких країнах воно
функціонуватиме як саме При посольствах
чи ні можете коротко про свої плани
розповісти Дякую вам дійсно в минулий
рік ми організовували складання в інших
країнах не про що поспіхом але там була
обмежена кількість часу в 32-х країнах в
нас діяли екзаменаційні центри
як представництва українського центру
оцінювання якості освіти за кордоном це
було 52 міст Але в цьому році ми
принаймні зберігаємо ті 302 країни і і
ведемо діалог про розширення саме мережі
складання
екзамени- мережі складання національного
предметного тесту за кордоном купити
максимальну кількість наших громадян
випускників які перебувають за кордоном
а основні якісь країни
ну це майже всі країни всі країни
Євросоюзу це Сполучені Штати Америки Це
була Японія була Туреччина були ще
Канада було декілька років про це
питають тому що ну традиційно мислимо
категоріями Європейського Союзу де
найбільше 8 мільйонів приблизно
українців в межах Європейського Союзу
перебуває а коли заходить мова про те що
хтось же ж виїхав справді і в Японію як
ви кажете Сполучені Штати прийняли
Канада прийняла там теж є випускники ми
це самий розглядаємо саме кількість і
агломерацію сьогоднішньої наших
випускників які перебувають в тій чи
іншій країні і ведемо перемовини із
посольствами і з представництвами
наприклад більшою частиною це є
університети ті країни які в яких
перебувають велика кількість наших
випускників і в цьому контексті саме при
університетах більшості організовували
саме центр складання
національного бюджету за кордоном
вони міністра якраз хочеться зрозуміти є
приблизно хоча б зараз уявлення А
скільки випускників будуть цього року
складати цей мультипредметний тест І
якщо є таке уявлення то яка з них
частина перебуває за кордоном України а
яка всередині це робитиме
ми в цілому будемо мати
Початок реєстрації в квітні місяці на
національний мультиплектний тести більш
неповно вже будемо
десь наприкінці травня мати можливість
зробити якусь яку інфографіку
зараз
підвиструшки наш зв'язок заморозився
Зараз ми перенаберемо
Сергія шкарлу та міністра освіти і науки
України ось підказують мені що
повернувся зв'язок та ми перебили нас
перебили зв'язок на фразі про те що у
квітні коли буде почнеться реєстрація
тоді можна буде приблизно ці цифри
скласти Отож реєстрація почнеться у
квітні скільки вона триватиме п міністра
буде тривати зараз відповідно до умов
прийому які ще не затверджені а і ми
маємо говорити про сам процес виключно
після того як вчена Ой як Верховна Рада
дозволить нам взагалі-то сформувати саме
нмт як інструмент вступу до закладів
освіти в 2023 році Так бо це те з чого
ми починали для того щоб
мультипредметний тест провести потрібно
рішення Верховної Ради Оскільки у нас
згідно з Законом ЗНО нас є
причиною і підставою для вступу
подальшого добре в такому разі в квітні
почнеться реєстрація на мультипредметний
тест будемо вважати що Верховна Рада
проголосує а сам мультиппредметний тест
за вашими планами коли має відбутися
Дякую за запитання Ми плануємо червень
липень основна сесія липень додаткова і
можливо будемо розглядати ще спеціальну
сесію в серпні або у вересні місяці
Ага тобто буде можливість протягнути це
в часі так не було в 22-му році Так ну і
зважаючи на те що частина абітурієнтів
теоретично може приїхати з тимчасово
окупованих територій
їм треба дати таку можливість
Необов'язково приїжджати вони можуть
складати за окремою процедурою
дистанційно
[музика]
добре і залишається мало часу але
все-таки пане міністри у нас не секрет
багато людей виїхало багато абітурієнтів
виїхали частина з них буде вступати за
кордоном і кількість студентів в Україні
з об'єктивних причин зменшується а чи
зменшується у нас кількість вищих які
будуть приймати цих студентів
знову у нас
проблема під час війни під час війни
якщо чуєте мене о чуєте тепер чую пане
Сергію так
прив'язувати скорочення університетів до
кількості потенційних абітурієнтів на
сьогодні вважаю некоректним оскільки в
нас повністю забезпечена можливість
дистанційного навчання в тому чи іншому
університеті навіть якщо дитина або
студент виїхали за кордон тому ми
сьогодні маємо проект світлового банку
який передбачає аудит щодо пропозицій
оптимізації мережі закладів вищої освіти
але це я точно вважаю що коректно це
робити після закінчення воєнних дій
після перемоги
це так казати Добре дякую пане Сергію що
знайшли час відповісти на наші запитання
вам результативного робочого дня знаючи
він сьогодні у вас напружений Сергій
шкарлет Міністр освіти і науки України
був гостем нашої студії марафон Відні
новини Буквально за кілька хвилин
продовжимо випуском новин